hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on Monster Hunter roldugin
and today we're gonna be showing you how
to get the new assassin's creed armor
which is called the byuk layered armor
who I believe is from Assassin's Creed
origins been a long time since I've
played Assassin's Creed but yeah we're
gonna show today how to get it what the
quest is some little tidbits and tips
like that
so let's get started with today's video
so first up it's a new event quest
that's only gonna be available on Xbox
one and ps4 so PC players you will not
have this just yet but if you're a PC
player you do actually have access to
both usj quests so you can actually get
those but for the PlayStation and Xbox
one players the new event quest is gonna
be in the event tab called SDF or silent
deadly and fierce is going to have you
fly an autogiro on a deviljho
and a balloon Astro all in the special
arena so this is gonna be pretty
interesting when you first start Oda
Garan and deviljho are gonna be in the
arena just together chillin out o
together on the top a double Joe on the
bottom once you beat the two of them Lou
Nostra will eventually come out and then
you have a one-on-one with her which is
really nice that they're all not
cluttered and it's just this huge
[ __ ] I took out the o2 guru nor
the addo Guren whatever he's supposed to
actually be called I took him out first
and then I took out deviljho second it
really is no order personally it's
whatever you feel fit and then you can
go in fight lunesta afterwards if you
need help on what exactly they're weak
to I do believe that
odo Guren is weak to ice I believe
deviljho is weak to dragon and ice is
also Loon Astra's weakness so you can
couple those a little bit I also do
believe that thunder works for deviljho
as well so definitely try to use those
in conjunction throughout the fight or
as that this will help this a lot a very
simple very easy quest nothing too hard
got it first try and then once you beat
it you will get this thing called they
send you feather once you take that to
the smithy he will talk about this
mysterious assassin feather and stuff
like that and you will get access to the
layered armor set called by ik all you
need is two sinew feathers and then if
you talk to the lady across from the
smithy she will give you a specialized
tool called the assassins hood and that
also is going to require two sinew
feathers so I do believe you have to do
this about four times or I'm not
entirely sure if you can get more than
one I personally was unlucky and only
got one but you would technically have
to do this a maximum of four times to
get all of this stuff and yeah that's
really about it very simple quest not
really entirely sure what Assassin's
Creed has to do with Monster
or anything like that but we're just
gonna leave it that way so if you're an
assassin's creed fan you can get the new
armor it's really cool personally I do
like it myself I'm gonna be going to do
this after this video is up I'm gonna be
running this a couple times so I can get
the hood and stuff like that let's see
how that goes
yeah guys just remember that you would
want to mostly be wanting to use ice for
thunder or dragon weapons as that will
help to fight them is and if you're
unsure you can always check the monster
guide and stuff like that you guys like
the V if you do enjoy subscribe if
you're new I cover most of the solo
guides of Muslim monsters a must owner
world and I do be plant I will be
planning on making a guide for every
single Monster whether they're easy or
hard within the ice borne DLC coming
later next year so be on the lookout for
that even though that is a long time
away and I also plan on doing a guide
for 18 erdogan say when he hopefully
releases somewhere between January and
February let's also look out for that my
two most recent videos will be on the
screen if you guys do want to check that
out with that guys hope I have a great
yesterday thing for watching the video
enjoy the new assassin's creed armor and
peace out